fed chairman Jerome Powell had some
incredible comments today at the
inaugural Conference of the
international rules of the US dollar
yeah that's a real thing he thinks that
there's two main things occurring right
now first is that there's rapid changes
are taking place in the global monetary
system that may affect the international
role of the US dollar I tend to agree
with Jerome Powell here there's lots of
different moving Parts the US dollar has
been being devalued intentionally
there's all sorts of conversations
around what the role will be on the
international stage after the U.S
decided to Levy incredible historic
sanctions against Russia during the
Russia Ukraine conflict and of course
many other countries are now saying
maybe we shouldn't be dependent on the
US dollar if it's going to be
politicized and weaponized on the
international stage not only though does
Jerome Powell call out the ever-changing
role of the US Dollar on the
international markets but he also stated
that a central bank digital currency may
be a path to continue to extend the US
dollar dominance in the global market
now of course Central Bank digital
currencies sound awesome they look over
at the crypto market and they see the
rapid rise of stable coins and how
popular those assets are both for
financial Market participants and
everyday citizens but there are major
concerns around Central Bank digital
currencies for example it may
drastically increase the financial
surveillance of the government on the
everyday citizen it also can introduce
things like personalized monetary policy
if you're a good boy you get low
inflation if you're a bad boy you get
high inflation and then on top of that
it also introduces things like
censorship where they can literally say
you can't spend money on those movie
tickets because you ate too much candy
this week now of course many people will
just simply laugh this off and they'll
say oh that's conspiracy theory talk but
we see in other countries like China
they're already doing this in those
countries they've even gone a step
further and they've introduced the idea
of the expiration of money they simply
will give you money from the government
in the form of a stimulus check and if
you don't spend it within a
predetermined amount of time it simply
disappears and now you may say that
it'll never happen in the United States
but it already does happen in the U.S if
you look at something like EBT cards
they give you money and if you don't use
it for what they tell you to spend it on
in 12 months it literally goes away and
so naturally essential Bank digital
currency well it may sound like a good
idea there's a lot of concern around the
powers that it would introduce on the
national stage for a government that
might not necessarily be a great Steward
of those powers and so at the end of the
day the US Dollar's role is changing
there's a lot of people asking a lot of
questions Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
are driving a conversation around free
market competition the end users
ultimately want to use something that
allows them to store value use it as a
medium of exchange and allows them to
conduct their day-to-day business
without worrying about will this have
value in the future or will somebody not
allow me to use it for the purposes that
I want the end of the day Jerome Powell
the Federal Reserve the treasury elected
officials and many other people in
positions of power and influence it a
lot of thinking to do because if they
want the US dollar to remain the
dominant form of money in the global
market they've got to do something
different because it's headed in the
wrong direction and that might not be
good for the United States of America
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time